i want to give a special shout out to
everybody who's been supporting project
hood
everybody who's been praying for project
hood believing for project hood and
giving the project good i want to say
thank you so very much
also those who have been
blessing our church in my absence i'm so
appreciative of all the things that
you've done for us and i just want to
leave you with this
that there is absolutely nothing
and i mean absolutely nothing
that you and god together cannot
accomplish
[Music]
[Applause]
hello i'm miles mendoza and i'm on the
roof with pastor brooks hi i'm t in
portland oregon i'm also on the roof of
pastor brooks hi my name is joe cheney
i'm on the roof with pastor brooks hello
i'm ashley jacobs and i'm on the roof of
pastor brooks currently in bogota
colombia and i too am on the rooftop
with pastor brooks my name is sean c and
i am on the roof with pastor brooks my
name is ian rowe i am on the roof with
pastor corey brooks hi it's beth from
moment and i'm on the roof with castor
brooks my name is tj my name is lily and
we're on the roof for pastor brooks i'm
tyronna jones actress and director and i
am on the roof with our fierce leader
pastor corey brooks
hello everyone my name is romelo i am in
africa in the country of ghana and i'm
on the roof of pastor brooks
[Applause]
i am bob woodson and i am on the roof
with pastor brooks hi my name is brian
alexander and i'm on the roof with
pastor brooks
i am glenn lowery in providence rhode
island and i am on the rooftop with
pastor brooks i'm dumasani washington
and i'm on the roof with pastor corey
brooks hi my name is dr sabo o'boor and
i'm on the roof of pastor corey brooks
i'm david hokey and i'm on the roof
pastor corey brooks this is pastor scott
ziegler from the bridge church in
chicagoland and we are on the roof with
pastor corey brooks i'm jim overweight
and i've been on the rooftop with pastor
corey brooks my name is alicia martin
and i'm on the roof with pastor corey
brooks i'm pastor steve bozeman new
beginnings church of atlanta and i'm on
the roof with cory brooks hi we're the
joseph's from will matt and we're on the
roof with pastor brooks yo i'm dez from
the project hood team and we're live on
the roof with pastor brooke hi i'm
elizabeth i'm in arizona and i'm on the
rooftop with pastor brooks this is betsy
hart from momet and i am on the roof
with pastor brooks hi my name is aaron
mel and i'm on the roof with pastor
brooks i'm apostle h daniel wilson i'm
on the roof with pastor corey brooke
hello my name is pastor james meeks and
i'm on the roof with pastor corey brooks
hi my name is shelby steele my heart is
on the roof with pastor brooks hey my
name is jim purcell and i'm on the roof
with pastor corey brooks
hi i'm pastor rani from ethiopia
and i'm on the roof is bastard force hi
i'm mary lou hutchinson and i'm up here
on the roof of pastor corey brooks i'm
markee and i'm on the roof of pastor
floyd brooks i'm demarious langston and
i'm on the roof of pastor corey brooks
peace
it's linda williams out here and i'm on
the roof
with pastor cory brooks hi my name is
imario and i'm on the roof for pastor
brooks
hey cory it's gary rabine and nick
raymond and uh we got to tell you we're
there with you brother we're on the roof
with you we were with you a few weeks
ago we wish we could be there with you
every day because uh you know what
you're an amazing guy and it's awesome
what you're doing for your community so
thank you so much god bless you happy
new year and thanks for being on the
roof brother
[Applause]
yeah that's nice i'm impressed